i said he is quite a strong player
so now we play alexander rosen a russian
grandmaster
and it is underrated which is safe
okay knights of three knight f6 what do
we play here maybe g4
e6 okay let's try bishop g5
magnus style c5
yeah i think d5 is possible here
or maybe not but i think it is
he goes d6 quickly wow
this is strange okay can i play nexus 3
or something or c4
or e4 i mean something okay nexus 3
looks normal
and e4 looks normal as well
i mean it allows knight takes d5 but i'm
fine with it somehow
maybe i should not be fine with it
actually
but yeah i guess i'm fine i'll just go
eds and i have b5 checks and dtx6 and
he goes for it i think it's a mistake
that is my bet okay i guess we can just
call this we'll just take
go bishop b5 check i guess he will play
king of fade
yeah so now at very least we can take on
a 6 on
e6 take on g5 and play
play quintx d6 check there at very least
i mean i feel like
we could actually have a a better idea
here
what do you think about that ending in
the end by the way is it better for us
it could be better
so we will castle long and then we're in
time to play 95 check him
okay let's try this
at least it's sort of rock solid for
white obviously so just take
take he plays queen e7
[Music]
and we probably
is there a difference i mean
it should not be a mistake to castle so
he takes on d6
then we take k7
and we start thinking there
yeah now i feel like it kind of it kind
of makes sense to
remove the rook from the six so rook
requests to d1 probably leads nowhere
he'll just play e6
bishop a2 knight c6 and then knight d4
is coming
which is a bit unpleasant
and we will not really will not really
have a chance to ignore it
so that's why we have to remove the rook
right now i guess
but the goose new the good news is that
probably it's still better for white
i mean that's how i felt list
so after let's say a6 we can even
consider uh
playing rookie 1 8 xb5 95
check king d6 and v6 and so on
yeah he plays rook d8 that's what i was
talking about in the very beginning so
now we can just take on d8 play rook d1
check and knight d5
and that is definitely better for white
the question is if we have a better move
maybe we don't need a better move okay
let's just play this simple
you can check
yeah so there is no good square like c
see it looks
looks weird and then c7 and e7 both
round to
run into 95 check which leads to
to quite a pleasant quite a pleasant
ending for white
i mean of course you don't lose it
quickly it's black but it's
uh it's definitely better
for us
yeah goes there 95 he'll probably take
go e6 i guess yeah so now my
plan was to play bishop d3 and bishop f5
does it work
yeah i think it does
so now we'll probably win a poem
which should normally lead to you know
two very big guests now we can even
trade rooks by the way
which is probably
which is probably good option or maybe
not
okay let's try this doesn't really
matter
at least i will not wonder rook
that is already good news
yeah so can i play bishop d3 now
knight g4 f3 and then i try to
[Music]
try to win the night i probably can
okay f3 he goes here okay then we just
go
g3 and let's say if we just go king d2
and chase him away
now i think it's just completely lost to
be honest
yeah now bishop c4 just wins another
problem
or he has to yeah to play the pawn
ending which is completely lost as well
yeah he resigns thanks for the game
tough one